I have some very very big news to break
to you right now I was just with BTS and
I know that you had said you'd love to
collaborate with them and I asked them
do you accept and they said yes it would
be honored to collaborate Your Honor I
would be honored yes hi there before you
I will see them
what if talking yeah is it about them I
think there's something about them being
themselves and a little bit geeky and I
think people like people who are natural
and it seems like they're being
themselves and I love that tonight
Selina is performing for the first time
since her surgery I know you guys are
close you've worked together
any thoughts going into that I'm sure
she's really excited it's the big moment
for her nerve-wracking it's
nerve-wracking in a good way though and
I'm sure she'll be super happy once
she's done I'm sure she's really nervous
right now but I'm happy for what do you
have coming up I'm about to finish my
next single right now I'm in the process
I'm hoping to get it done before the
next year so I will start the year with
a new song and then I want to lock
myself in at some point for a month or
two and work on an album is there
collaborator on it is it just you it is
a collaboration always come on you know
it's the collaboration I think everybody
will be really happy to hear talk to me
a little bit of the pressure of being at
the American Music Awards I think I've
just always been myself and that's the
easiest way to do things no matter where
you are and luckily there's a lot of
artists here that I love and that I
would probably be really nervous to say
hi to so if any of them say hi to me
that makes it easier for me okay and
other than that I think it's a great
moment to meet each other and maybe
collaborate in the future me that's what
I'm all about you know I'm about making
music with people that I love
[Music]
you